[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and we recently
witnessed the birth of a new phenomenon
within the anime meme community with the
release of neo yo kyo a six episode
Netflix original animated series created
by Ezra Koenig neo yo kyo follows the
story of a high society majestic rat
named Kaz Khan voiced by Jaden Smith as
he tries to balance his time between
brooding over a recent breakup
exorcising demons throughout the city
and trying to be an elegant gentleman
slash field hockey player now because
the animation style of neo yo Keough was
heavily influenced by anime and many
themes and tropes in the show are direct
references to anime including the title
itself of course it is no surprise that
many members of the anime community felt
the urge to weigh in on this series from
what I've seen most people seem to think
that Neo yo Kyo is either really bad or
so bad that it's good and they can't
believe such amazing voice acting talent
went into such a bad show including the
likes of Jude Law Susan Sarandon and
Steve Buscemi some notable videos that
I've seen which addressed Neo Tokyo
include videos from Liu talks anime the
RPG monger and Baron J I definitely
recommend checking out their videos
links will be in the description but I
decided to make my own video because I
have a pretty different take on this
whole thing I don't think that Neo yo
Kyo is bad at all it's actually
brilliant for what it is trying to be
and no I'm not going to say psych at
some point in this video and tell you
that this was all a joke and I think the
show is trash I genuinely liked it and I
knew that I would like it as soon as I
saw that one of the characters is named
Archangel oh not Angelo Ark Angelo how
deliciously pretentious I laughed out
loud as soon as I saw this and that's
when I was hooked
the problem that we seem to
be running into as an anime community is
that because it uses an anime aesthetic
or art style neo ukyo is being judged by
anime standards but we need to get this
straight
right off the bat neo yo Kyo is not an
anime it is a Western cartoon that pays
homage to anime and for those of you who
are not French weaves like me it pays
homage to anime there are definitely a
ton of animate ropes and cliches that
fans of anime will recognize in the
oh-yo kyo random skirt shots
hikiko mori idol culture demon girls
mecca's and so on nevertheless while
paying tribute to anime at its core neo
yo Kyo is far more similar to Western
adult cartoons like Bojack horseman and
Archer vent to anime and this is why we
need to remember that what makes anime
anime is not just an art style the
unique cultural and historical context
also plays a key role and for this
reason avatar is not an anime and
neither is neo yo kyo that said there
are numerous blatant references to anime
in new yoyo kyo including the exorcist /
demon slayer / supernatural detective
genre in anime science fiction themes
inspired by anime like akira teen
romance themes and settings similar to
mole rod host club and Nagi ah su and
there are even direct and or indirect
references to works of sci-fi authors
like William Gibson and philip k dick oh
and is that a [ __ ] Hamlet
reference Neo yo kyo is at its core a
beautiful mess that combines some of the
craziest aspects of anime with some of
the most outrageous elements of Western
culture and to put it simply neo yo kyo
is what happens when all Ron host club
meets daily lives of high-school boys
meets Bojack horseman meets big Tobler
olds the first thing we need to
understand when watching neo yo Kyo is
the type of humor it intentionally
embraces Neil yo Kyo embraces a surreal
or absurdist comedy style which to quote
Wikipedia
is a form of humor predicated on
deliberate violations of causal
reasoning producing events and behaviors
that are obviously illogical the humor
derived gets its appeal from the fact
that the situation described is so
ridiculous or unlikely the whole point
of such humor is to be unrealistic
absurd and over-the-top in order to
shine a spotlight on the absurdity of
the real world by exaggerating to the
point of absurdity it subverts our
expectations and forces us to think
about the actual absurdity in the real
world in our own world in neo yo kyo in
particular the main themes covered are
the general malaise and meaninglessness
of modern urban life along with the
absurd elitism vanity luxury and social
inequality of modern society however as
I said earlier these themes are explored
through exaggerated and absurd
situations which are not meant to be
realistic they are meant to be so
outrageous that they make us stop and
think wait modern society could not
possibly be anything like this could it
good example of similar absurdist
surreal and satirical cartoons are as
mentioned earlier Bojack horseman and
Archer but also the early seasons of
FAMILY GUY films like Napoleon Dynamite
and Borat and of course Adult Swim shows
like Harvey Birdman attorney at law this
type of comedy is not for everyone
many find it to be too outlandish to
relate to but Neil yoki Oh actually fits
really well within this sub-genre going
into neo yo kyo and expecting a serious
attempt to make a sophisticated anime
series is like going into Keijo
expecting a serious sports anime or
going into one punch man and expecting a
Dark Knight esque
gritty superhero story we have to take
neo yo Kyo for what it is and for what
it is it's brilliant
the animation is not great by any means
the music is all over the place and the
show cannot compare to the kind of
quality we have become accustomed to
with most anime but I genuinely enjoyed
neo yo Kyo and I thought it was
hilarious I noticed that a lot of
critics seem to think that neo yo Kyo
takes itself seriously but fails as a
serious show but I do not think that neo
yo Kyo takes itself seriously for a
second for instance I firmly believe
that the melodramatic classical music
interspersed with sudden bursts of jazz
and other genres was not intended to
make the show seem more serious but just
the opposite it is a satire of melodrama
and the fact that inside neo yo Kyo
there is an underground club that plays
grigory and house music says at all in
my mind the absurd situations and
characters the endless parade of anime
tropes and references the protagonists
over-the-top vanity and melodramatic
brooding over pointless [ __ ] and of
course the epic rival Arcangelo I loved
at all Arcangelo is such a cliche overly
competitive douchebag rival character
that it's actually hilarious and in fact
if I'm being honest I prefer him to many
of the rival characters we've seen in
recent popular anime Arcangelo is a
self-obsessed pretentious douchebag to
the core but at least he's open and
honest about it
and at least he does it in style and
this random surreal outlandish humor is
enough for me to enjoy the show on its
own but you can also dig deeper into the
symbolism and meaning behind the show if
you really want to for instance I've
seen a lot of criticism directed at the
main character cast conned
because he is vain shallow melancholic
and doesn't really undergo any
meaningful development throughout the
series but that's exactly the point he
is a product of the society of neo yo
Kyo and it isn't easy to overcome social
conditioning and see outside the box if
that box is all you've ever known if
Kass could change so easily
and suddenly become a better person then
the social commentary would be far less
potent if it were so easy to escape the
shackles of conformity that modern
society places upon us then anyone could
do it but it isn't easy and that's the
point
after all in real life many people never
quote-unquote develop at all they remain
greedy vain and pretentious for their
entire lives whoever in no yoki oh we do
have helymus and Tesoro and she is a
character who sees outside the box a
former fashion blogger who built a Jake
Paul er esque following through her
online fashion blogging she comes to see
the absurdity of modern society and
rebels against it by rejecting
fashionable clothing and the meaningless
social spectacles of neo ukyo's high
society through Helena we get to
experience the full extent of Neal
ukyo's absurdity and because of her our
protagonist Kaz begins to reevaluate
some of his priorities if ever so
slightly when he eventually decides to
help her and of course we also have the
famous big Toblerone which can be said
to have important symbolic meaning as
well one could argue that the big
Toblerone represents the strong desire
for social acceptance that so many of
the characters in neo yoyo express and
the Toblerone is therefore a symbol of
conformity if you conform to society's
expectations then you deserve a big
Toblerone but if you don't then no
Toblerone for you finally cast a
protagonist may not be a simplistic of a
character as we think he could be looked
at as the Millennial Hamlet an
indecisive melancholic self-hating
existentialist madman but he is not to
blame for this not entirely because he
is the product of his society and is the
Society of neo yoki oh really that
different from our society
that is the question that we are left
with and it is an interesting one all
things considered and regardless of
whether you like me or yo kyo for its
humor or its underlying themes or
whether you just hate everything about
it I think that it's a great thing that
neo yo Kyo exists it's very existence
proves that anime is becoming globally
recognized to the point that an entire
Netflix series with a star-studded cast
would pay tribute to anime in such a
direct way as long as we don't expect it
to be something that it's not as long as
we don't compare it to high quality
anime and just enjoy it for the
satirical and surreal anime inspired
American comedy that it is there will be
plenty of big Toblerone z' to go around
for everyone now if you enjoyed this
video be sure to leave a like in order
to help me move up in the most eligible
bachelor rankings and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell as always
thank you so much for watching and until
next time see us space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]